When the Berlin Wall fell, there was an
American State Department official named
Francis Fukuyama.
And he wrote a very influential essay
called The End of History.
And
for decades
capitalism was in a struggle with
communism.
And in his essay
Fukuyama argued
that the triumph of capitalism would
come to the end of history. Meaning we
now know what humanity must strive for,
which is a liberal
consumer democracy, where people feel
empowered
to have the freedom to buy whatever they
want. And this for him was the apex of
human civilization.
And this creates what is called the
unipolar moment.
Where America
is the global hegemon. And it creates a
world that is heavily globalized
capitalistic
um and very individualistic.
And this is a very unique moment in
human history. And we've come with this
one Iran to the end of this moment.
All right? So, let me first explain the
three major characteristics of this
unipolar moment.
The first is what I call Pax Americana.
Where American power
American
military might guaranteed peace in the
entire world. And this is unique in
human history, where for the first time
there was a power that was able to
dominate the entire globe. And America
was able to do so through three
mechanisms, okay? The first is of course
its military power, but
but specifically aerial supremacy.
Okay? Which is backed up by special
forces
and [clears throat] the CIA.
So, the CIA was able to infiltrate every
single government in the world and
identify who would be loyal to the
American Empire and then promote this
person. If there were individuals that
challenged the American Empire, these
people were demoted or eliminated.
Nations that proved problematic, for
example, maybe Syria or Libya, special
Special forces went in to sabotage the
economy and then aerial power went in to
destroy the government. And um
so, this created Pax Americana. Now,
what's good about this is that it did
bring peace to very problematic regions.
For example, in Indonesia,
>> [clears throat]
>> Japan, South Korea, and North Korea,
China, Vietnam not compete against each
other, they just participate in the
global economy, which brought tremendous
wealth
and prosperity to uh the East Asia
region. This is true also in Europe uh
and South America as as well, okay? So,
um aerial supremacy. Then you have
something called surveillance.
And basically what I mean by that is the
internet.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, believe it or not, but the internet
was created not not to actually help you
communicate and to watch pornography, it
was actually to to have
um a mass surveillance system over the
entire human population so that the
Pentagon, the military knew exactly the
vibe or the culture, uh the attitudes,
the emotions of each region. And through
social media, through mechanisms such as
Facebook and Twitter, they were able to
manipulate certain emotions. Okay? So,
the second mechanism is mass
surveillance through the popularization
of the internet.
Um and the third is something called a
rules-based international order.
Okay, what this means is
American power hid behind multilateral
organizations such as the
uh United Nations, such as the World
Bank, such as the World Trade
Organization. And so, people didn't
notice
that the American uh empire was
strong-arming everything. They believed
that the world was fair and just, and
through uh logic and reason and debate,
they could present their case.
All right? So, for the longest time,
this Pax Americana provided peace and
stability to the world, which brought
tremendous prosperity.
>> [clears throat]
>> All right, so that's number one. Number
two
is the supremacy of science.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, for most of human history,
people were religious. They believed in
gods.
But,
with the rise of Pax Americana, science
became the dominant religion of the
whole world. All right, so
the classic example is COVID.
COVID was raging all across the world,
and then they issued vaccines.
Now,
I teach critical thinking skills. So,
when I first heard about the vaccines, I
was a bit skeptical. I said to my
friends who were Chinese and American, I
said, "You know,
um vaccines used used to take about 10
years to to develop, and that's when the
virus is stable and it had been around
for centuries. But this COVID is
constantly mutating and they haven't
have done enough trial research. So, is
it really safe to take this these
vaccines?
And whether they were Chinese or
American, their response was the same,
which is, "How dare you question
science? You are a peasant.
Have you gone to school? Have you no
culture?
Can you not think?"
Okay? And it shows you the how science
has become the new religion
of the world. And you think about it,
the scientists around the world, they're
actually transnational priests. Okay?
And science is an international
brotherhood, where if you're a scientist
in China, you're not you're not actually
loyal to China, you're actually loyal to
the international order of science
because that's how you get promoted,
right? You get published in Nature or
Science. If you win an award, like a
Nobel Nobel Prize, that's how you how
you get rewarded, okay? So, you're
better off being loyal to the
brotherhood brotherhood of science
rather than your own nation-state. And
of course, it is the American empire
that controls science.
>> [snorts]
>> And the third, um, unique aspect of the
European movement is, of course, the
universality
of the US dollar.
And it's kind of like you think about
think about where just a piece of paper,
you think it's gold. You think there's
value in it.
And not just you, but everyone around
you, so that you take your US dollars,
you go anywhere in the world and buy
yourself a villa or, uh, enjoy a nice
vacation or fly around.
But not only that, but you aspire like
to accumulate as
as much US dollars as possible,
right? Is there really a difference
between $100 million
and $100 million? There's absolutely no
difference. You can't spend it. But you
want to achieve as much as possible. And
as a result, you
um focus your entire life on
accumulating as much as possible. Okay?
So, these are the three main pillars of
the unipolar moment. And again, in the
beginning, which was maybe the early
'90s, this led to tremendous peace and
prosperity throughout the world.
The problem, though, is that over time,
these three pillars started to decay.
Right? So,
um
Pax Americana started to itself ignore
the rules-based natural order, which
itself created.
Right? So, America started to bomb
countries such as uh Libya and Syria
without international approval.
Most recently, it went to attack Iran
without even asking for the opinion of
the world, without even caring what the
what the world thought. Okay?
So, this leads the idea of hubris.
Maybe the first generation appreciates
the importance of collaboration,
of consensus. But the second generation,
the children, are arrogant. They have
hubris. They want to enjoy their power.
Okay? So, that's problem one. The
problem with science,
um
uh religion, basically becomes a
religion in itself, orthodoxy.
So, that science does not become the
main engine of innovation in the world,
it becomes the main uh engine of
orthodoxy or suppression. That's why for
the past 20, 30 years, we've seen very
little in terms of technological
innovation.
Don't tell me Silicon Valley is a center
of innovation in the world, okay? All
they do is make food delivery apps.
It's been a long time since we've seen
massive innovation in the world. What
we've seen in these past 20, 30 years is
the scaling out, the popularization of
innovation, right? Where American
technology is spread throughout the
world, especially in China. But we have
not seen actually major innovation in
science itself. All right. And the third
thing, the university of the US dollar
leads to
um printing
dollars, okay? Or just basically
corruption.
Where because America is able to print
as much US dollars as it wants to fund
its corruption,
it does so, okay? So the US dollar has
has lessened in value. And what this
means is basically it's made inequality
worse, it's made corruption worse, it's
made people very lazy. If you're a young
person, you're like, "You know what? No
matter how hard I work, I'm still
screwed in the end because the boomers,
the older generation, have so much more
money than I do. I can never catch up.
So I I refuse to play this game. Either
I refuse to play this game, so I quiet
quit, you know, complaining like like
that, or I gamble.
I pray that my put I'm going to lost in
Bitcoin, it'll go up to $10 million or
or or the stock market or sports
betting, okay? That's why in America
gambling has become so popular.
All right? So this has led to
uh today basically.
All right? So
um it's we shouldn't see this war
against Iran as just a decision of one
person, Donald Trump, or the
machinations of a country, Israel.
Really, this war in Ukraine is happening
because we come to the end of the
unipolar moment because
uh the American empire has become
corrupt, self-indulgent, lazy, arrogant.
All right?
So,
with the end of the American empire,
with the end of Pax Americana, we are
shifting towards a new world.
And this new world, some will survive,
most will not, okay? Because And this is
true throughout history where an empire
declines and the world order is
shifting, where there's a paradigm
shift,
people are forced to make a hard choice
of either adapt or die.
All right? So, let me show share with
you what how how the world needs to
change if it is to survive.
Basically, what has to happen is
we have to move from an
emphasis on efficiency
to
resilience.
Okay? That is the main
goal
in the future. Today, it's really about
how to make things as cheap as possible
and get get it to as many people as
quickly as possible to make as much
money as possible, okay? The idea of
efficiency.
Generating as much profit as possible.
The idea of resilience is to is to
appreciate that there will be a series
of crises and what you need to do is
focus on adapting and surviving these
crises, okay?
So, for a nation, for a community to
survive in the future, there have to be
three major changes.
If you're able to make these three
um major changes, you will survive. If
you do not [clears throat] make these
changes, you will be eliminated, okay?
It will be survival of the fittest.
All right. So, the first thing you need
to do is move from
materialism
to spirituality.
Right now, the entire world, these
nation-states, have convinced the
population
what matters is your material
well-being.
If you are driving a car, if you have a
house,
if you have enough food to eat, then you
should shut up and obey
because we're doing a good job.
Okay? But, in the future, governments
can't do that because there's not enough
resources to go around. Therefore,
therefore, the government has to make
you believe that what matters is
your happiness, your well-being, your
spirituality. And that that usually
means um a renewed focus on religion.
Okay? That's the first thing.
Second thing is to move from system of
individuality
to community
and family.
All right. And what this means is today
what you're taught in school, what
you're taught in society is what matters
is
you, me, okay? The ego.
If if if it's doing well for me, it's
good. I don't actually care about other
people. In the future, you have to focus
on building a community, on helping
others.
Okay?
And the last
um
um major shift is from the old to the
young. Okay? And this is very simple.
And this is actually the hardest thing
to do, which is like today, most
countries, especially the wealthy
Western industrial nations, are
controlled by the baby boomers, the
elderly, the gerontocracy.
They have all the money, they have all
the power.
But, for society to thrive in the
future, this power needs to shift to a
younger generation. Ideally, maybe in
their 30s, okay? The younger the better.
And you think this is easy to do? It's
not.
Because first of all, these baby boomers
have access to the best health care in
the world. They have a lot of money,
and they really enjoy living. And
they're also really selfish.
Okay? So, this is actually the hardest
problem to solve for most Western
societies. How do you transfer power
from the old to the young? And what I
see,
historically, we've never ever faced
this problem before. Never. Because the
old simply don't live that long, okay?
Now, baby boomers are living to at least
100 years old. So, they they have
another 20 years ahead of them in power.
Meanwhile, the young cannot uh
develop the experience and expertise in
order to lead the nation. So, whichever
nation actually speaks speaks out this
problem first, how do you really own and
give power to the young, then will most
likely thrive in the new world that's
coming.
And if you were if you were to ask me
which nation would most likely achieve
this first,
I would say Japan.
And the reason is very simple. Because
Japan in Japan this problem is the most
present. They are the um
um the oldest population. They have the
oldest population in the world. And so,
they they need to resolve this issue
really really quickly.
Okay? And maybe in the five next five 10
years, uh and I think that Japan will
actually resolve this issue. But
it may be the only nation that's able to
resolve this issue. Because it's so
difficult.
You love your grandparents. Do you want
to see your grandparents die?
Of course not. Okay, you're going
against human biological nature. All
right, okay. All right, so that's the
main argument I want to make you to
today, okay? So, what we're going to do
now is we're going to look at how the
world is going to transform because of
what's happening in the circle of moves,
because of this war in Iraq. Okay.
All right. So, basically we're in a new
world because our world today is built
on entirely entirely on access to cheap
petroleum products, cheap energy.
Right? Why are Why are you allowed to be
in school
learning from me rather than the fields
farming? Because of energy, right?
Because of oil from the Middle East.
Your computer is based on what?
Petroleum.
This camera that's filming me is based
on what? Petroleum. This pen, petroleum.
This clothing, petroleum.
The medicine you eat, petroleum. The
food that you eat comes from
fertilizers, which is based also on
petroleum. So, basically everything in
this room, everything in the world is
based on cheap petroleum. The entire
world economy, the main foundation is
cheap petroleum. So, what happens in a
world where petroleum is no longer
cheap?
Well, now you have a You need a massive
rebalancing in the world, okay?
The other thing about the world is
this is the GCC countries, okay?
Um uh the Middle East countries. And as
you can see, this is really important to
see is
um around the year 2005,
>> [clears throat]
>> they started to
have massive
massive
um account surplus. Meaning they were
selling so much oil, they couldn't
really spend all their money.
Do you guys know why?
What what was this happening?
What happened in 2005, 2004 that made
these countries extremely wealthy?
All right, China, okay.
>> [snorts]
>> Think about it. What is China doing?
Well, China in the '80s and '90s was
putting factories, right? But then it
China itself developed this a counter
plan. So, now China wants to develop its
industrial base, right?
And how do you do that? By importing oil
from the GCC.
Right?
And that's why we have these
skyscrapers, these malls, these roads,
okay? Because China was able to import
all this cheap oil from the GCC. And
then the GCC would take this money,
okay? And then invest it back into the
market stock market. But not just that,
they would invest it in Africa.
They would invest invest in
infrastructure. So, for the longest
time, the Chinese economy and the GCC
are the two main pillars
of the entire global economy.
Okay? And what this means is that if the
GCC no longer is able to
export oil, this is going to have a
major impact on China. And together, the
two are going to have a major impact on
the global economy, okay?
[clears throat] Basically, the global
economy is dead.
All right.
Okay, another thing that you may not be
aware of is today, flight flying around
the world it's very very simple to do.
You get up like if you want it what we
can do now is get our mobiles out, uh go
to a website, and look at where we're
going to fly to, and then book that
flight for tonight.
Pay using a credit card, take a taxi to
the airport, get on a flight, and we're
there the next morning.
That's really really impressive. Guess
what, guys? You couldn't do this 20
years ago. Okay? The technology was
around, but it was not um widely
available. Now, look at this, where the
entire world is interconnected, okay?
Um this is a pretty stark chart where in
1950, it was considered an a tremendous
luxury to fly. You had to be a
millionaire, basically, to want to fly
for vacation, okay? Everyone else just
drove their car.
Now, it's like anyone can drive. And
again, this happened just in the past,
basically, 30, 40 years. And this, of
course, is because of Pax Americana,
where Pax Americana will guarantee
there's a cop in the world, and
therefore, planes can just fly around.
Otherwise, be shot down.
Okay?
All right.
Well,
this world is coming to an end. In the
future, flights will be very expensive,
and vacations will be unaffordable,
okay?
All right.
This is the internet, guys. Now, you
don't know this. You think that the
internet is just a one computer, and
then, boom, the internet is there. No,
actually, the internet is under these
cables that connect the entire world.
And unfortunately,
uh there's a war going on right here,
guys.
And unfortunately, it's really easy for
Iran to cut off the underseas cables,
which would lead to internet disruption
for maybe 20, 30% of the world. Okay?
Africa, northern Africa, India, the
Middle East, maybe parts of Europe will
lose internet access. You think, "Okay,
well, that's fine. They just won't watch
Netflix anymore." No, guys, okay? The
entire world economy is based off the
cloud.
So, if want to bank,
if you want a basic finance, okay? This
is going to have a huge impact in the
world. And this can happen anytime.
Where for the reason there's a war going
on in the Strait of Hormuz, some cables
get get get cut off, and then suddenly
you've lost internet access. And this
would basically
cause major
um
disruptions throughout the world.
All right.
Okay. So, one thing that you notice
about this world is the sheer amount of
population growth. Where after World War
II, because of Pax Americana, you see a
massive boom in population.
And unfortunately,
this is not sustainable. It is not
possible for the planet to sustain 8
billion people. Many of whom want to fly
around the world every uh
twice a year. Who want to drive an SUV.
Who want to have food any who want to
have avocados
uh every single day. They want to have
like cherries every single day, okay?
So,
um
this population growth
um is not sustainable. And basically
what happens is this. When you are too
off balance, when there's a correction,
the correction is pretty extreme, okay?
So, this problem by itself, the fact
that we have so many people, means like
if there's a crisis,
the population will see a massive
shrinkage, okay? You're like, "Okay,
how?" And the answer is food scarcity.
Food is not is today pretty common, but
food is based on global trade, okay? So,
let me show you what I mean by this.
All right.
So, this the the yellow, okay, are
places that need fertilizer to grow
food, meaning their land is not uh good
for farming. So, they need fertilizer to
grow food. They also have large
population. As you can see, a lot of
this is based in uh Africa and
[clears throat] maybe Central Asia and
parts of South America. Ammonia
is chemical produced from oil to
petroleum that is fundamental for
fertilizers. And as you can see, this is
mainly in the north of the world. What
allows for 8 billion people is the fact
that
the north is able to export fertilizer
to the south. And that's it, guys. You
understand? If this were to stop for
whatever reason,
people in the south would be in a lot of
trouble.
All right? So, as you can see,
this trade in fertilizer is what
sustains a global population of 8
billion people. Again, if there is a
disruption to this trade,
the people in the south are in a lot of
trouble.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> So,
um if you're in the green, you're okay,
okay? But if you are in the red, you you
are in a lot of trouble, okay?
You are in a lot of trouble if you are
in if you are in
the
red.
But honestly, if you are not in the
green, you could still be in a lot of
trouble because again, what we're
looking for is resilience.
The idea of efficiency is let's imagine
the best case scenario and try to make
as much money out of it as possible,
okay? The idea of resilience is let's
imagine the worst case scenario and see
if we can survive it.
Basically, if you are if you have food
security issues,
you are facing a massive problem, okay?
Because again, we're imagining the worst
case scenario. And again, I hate to say
this, but you know that we you should be
worrying right now, okay? And and
where's China?
Not in the green dots, okay?
There's something that national leaders
in the world have been talking about
right now, food scarcity.
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> Water.
Again,
the countries that suffer from food
scarcity,
some of them also suffer from food
scarcity, okay? I
from water water scarcity.
Okay? All right, we got this. All right.
Okay? So, basically, this area
is not a problem. I would say that water
is far more problematic than food.
And again, I hate to say this, but if
you are
any country
here,
what's going on here?
>> [clears throat]
>> If you're any country in this area,
okay?
You should be worried.
Freedom is a very important issue
because freedom is actually important
for resilience issues, okay?
And what this means is that
when there's a crisis,
leaders and the population need to
collectively make sacrifices.
But when there's very little freedom,
meaning there's very little transparency
and accountability, where the public
don't have access
to the leadership, then the leadership
could possibly make
selfish, self-defeating decisions.
And it And the public is not involved,
and therefore the public refuses to make
the sacrifices necessary in order to
uh make the nation survive, okay?
And so, this leads to conflict around
the world. And again, countries that
um
suffer the most from food issues and
water issues also are most likely to
come into conflict
with other people, okay?
So, this is a map of nations at war. The
red means that they are at war, okay?
And you can see Africa and the Middle
East is
uh
especially
under a lot of conflict and a lot of
stress.
While at the same time they're suffering
from food scarcity and water issues.
All right? So,
what you will see uh sorry, another
issue I want to um bring up is that of
megacities.
And let me I mean megacities is any
cities that have over 10 million people.
And you think, "Wow, like megacities are
amazing cuz you have like shopping malls
and you have like skyscrapers. That's
great." No, no, no, guys. Megacities
are really bad, okay? Megacities should
not exist. They exist because of
globalization.
Because what megacities do is they're
able to bring in a lot of people, have
them specialize in a particular area,
make it industrial, and then export to
to the rest of the world, okay? And
where are most mega cities located?
Well, they're located in India and in
China.
This a problem because India and China
both suffer from food and water issues.
If you are to be resilient, you actually
want most of your population not in
cities, but in the countryside growing
food. Because first of all, they are
self-sufficient. Second of all, you will
have um a food supply. Unfortunately,
right now,
um China imports a quarter of its food.
And also remember, food also requires
energy to grow, right? So, China imports
75% of its oil.
This brings up the question of how
resilient is China. Okay, not just
China, but also any big country with a
mega city or too many mega cities, India
um
specifically, will face problems in the
future.
Again, if you're a national leader, you
should be worried right now, okay?
All right.
So,
with this war and disruptions to global
trade, we should expect massive
instability
in nations that are not very resilient,
okay? That have very little freedom,
that have food issues, and which have
water issues, okay? And so, you would
see revolutions, you would see wars, you
would see famines, which leads to what?
Which leads to massive migration,
okay? And so, these are trends. These
are migration trends that we're already
seeing where people from Africa, Middle
East are moving to Europe, and people
from um South America and Latin America
are moving to the United States, okay?
And we should expect these trends to not
only continue but to accelerate by maybe
maybe 100 times.
Okay?
And you think to yourself, okay, well,
what Europe and North America can do is
just build walls, right? They should
right now build a wall because you're
going to see a massive influx of
refugees due to
uh food and water issues.
And unfortunately,
Europe and North America have a huge
problem. The problem, of course, is
aging. Okay? So, in 2020, the countries
in purple are countries that have
a significant elderly population.
And this is 2050, where the entire
northern hemisphere will have
um an significant elderly population.
So, the north, the industrial economies,
are aging very rapidly, which means
their only option is to bring in cheap,
desperate
workers from the south who are fleeing
conflict zones
in order to
um run their economies.
Right? The problem with this of this, of
course, is that this will lead to
cultural conflict where the local
populations, native populations, will
feel they're being replaced by
um these refugees and these immigrants.
And this will probably lead to civil
conflict within
uh North America and within
Europe.
Okay?
And unfortunately,
there's really no way around
this issue.
Because the elderly are in control, and
they want people to mow their lawns.
They want people to
nurse them. They want people to deliver
food to them.
And unfortunately,
young people don't have to do that
because their parents have money.
Okay? So, one way around this issue is
by importing cheap immigrant labor.
Right?
Okay.
>> [clears throat]
>> With the end of Pax Americana, what you
will see emerge is regional trading
blocks. Basically, the idea of
mercantilism, okay?
Mercantilism.
And
for [clears throat] most of human
history, this was what we did. Where
there was no one power that controlled
the entire world, what happened was that
maybe you had a local hegemon, which
guaranteed trade
among its allies, okay? And you didn't
trade with other people, you only traded
within your regional trading block.
And that's the world we're heading back
towards, okay? So, this is
a map of the 17th 16th century, 17th
century, where, you know, you have these
mercantile empires, like the British,
the Portuguese, the French,
the Spanish, and they had their own
trade networks. And they refused to work
with each other, but the system worked
fine.
Okay? It's always more expensive, it was
not so convenient, but it still works.
So, this does not This does not mean the
end of global trade, it just means much
more limited global trade.
Right?
>> [clears throat]
>> Um another thing that you will notice
about the Asian economies is slaves
Slaves were a very important part
of the trade. And the reason why is
this:
You need energy to run your society.
Today we use oil, back then they used
human beings.
Right? You can no longer have access to
cheap oil, what you do is you enslave
people.
And that's the way historically we've
done things.
All right? Okay.
So, the last thing I want to talk about
is religion.
Because remember, the idea of resilience
is you need people to focus more on
spirituality and less on materialism
because if you they focus on
materialism, their lives are going to
get worse and worse. Okay? So, you need
to cause a national spiritual
rejuvenation in your country.
And if you are in the gray,
um you might have issues, okay? Why?
Because
your people are not religious
and too materialistic. And
unfortunately,
East Asia, okay? Japan,
uh
China, Korea,
Vietnam are especially
non-religious. That's going to be a
problem for them in the future, okay?
All right. So, let's just summarize what
we've learned so far. What are some
major trends that we should expect over
the next 10 to 20 years? Again, I just
say this, all right? If you really
believe that next week Donald Trump and
Iran are going to come to a peace
agreement, if you believe that
um maybe in five, six months both Iran
and the United States will exhaust
themselves, the global economy will
suffer too much, and then they'll just
stop the war and things will go back to
normal. I don't know I don't know what
to tell you, okay? You're living in a
fantasy world. You have to wake up and
recognize that this is the end of the
unipolar moment and we're moving towards
a new world. And you either choose to
adapt to this new world or you will die.
It's that simple.
All right? So,
massive trend is deindustrialization
and deurbanization
where
people in the cities will have to move
back to the countryside, especially
young people.
Okay? They have to learn like real
skills.
No more cryptocurrency trading for you
guys, okay? Learn how to milk a cow or
kill chicken
or grow food, whatever, okay? But just
do something useful for your life.
Um
nationalism and remilitarization is very
important where you have to get young
people who willing to fight and defend
your land. Okay? And that means getting
them to believe that your nation
deserves to be strong.
So, which every nations are most
ready and most able to excite their
young population into fighting wars will
will be the ones who will be most
resilient.
Uh mercantilist systems, basically
independent trading blocks.
Resource wars is a very big thing, okay?
Famines, genocides, slavery. Okay? So,
remember, for most of human history,
humans were the cheap energy.
If you don't have access to
cheap oil, well, then you're going to
enslave human beings.
All right? This is not a pretty future,
but it is a future that could happen and
you have to mentally prepare yourself
for this possibility.
Okay?
Um mass migration where people in the
south are most likely to suffer from
resource wars over water and food and
and people, so they escape from escape
to Europe and North America.
Okay?
Um revolution, civil wars, political
instability in America and in Europe
because
the baby boomers refuse to retire from
the scene. And these are aging
populations,
massive inequality, massive corruption,
massive stagnancy. And so this will lead
to chaos in the streets, okay?
Um religion is a big thing.
Um
if you are not religious, I actually
recommend
looking into the possibility of becoming
a religion, okay? It's been very useful
for what's going to happen later on.
Um this These are things I will talk
about more in the future, okay? But I
will bring them up now. Like how do I
see the world in 10, 20 years time? All
right? So I will say this.
I think
that there will be eventually an
alliance between Russia and Germany
in Europe.
Maybe for the next 5, 10 years, Germany
and Russia will go to war against each
other, but eventually what the two will
figure out is they're better off
actually working together than fighting
against each other.
Okay?
Um you have Pax Judaica. Remember the
entire point of this war in Iran from
Israel's perspective is to knock out
America from the Middle East and
establish itself as the local hegemon.
And then it becomes Pax Judaica.
Okay?
So I think Israel will come to dominate
the Middle East. But then you're like,
"What about Iran?" Okay. And like
I used to try to understand,
but
if the United States were to leave the
scene
and Israel and Iran had to go to war
against each other, what would happen is
they would say,
"Why?"
Because Israel is like, "I don't want
Persia." And then Iran is like, "I don't
want Israel." And Israel has nuclear
weapons. So, they would agree to split
the Middle East up where Iran controls
Shufu Moos,
and Israel controls the Levant, right?
Historically, actually,
um the Israelis, the Jewish people, they
hated the Greeks, they hated the Romans,
but they actually got very happy with
the Persians. So, there's this history
going back where where Persians and Jews
actually get along very well. And in
fact, um in the Middle East, the place
outside Israel with the largest Jewish
population is Iran.
And they're very well treated there.
Okay? So, I don't see why, if America
were to leave the scene, why
why couldn't Israel and Iran come to a
mutually satisfactory agreement that
benefits both nations, right?
Um Japan.
Again, I think the major problem facing
all Western industrial nations is the
aging crisis. What do you do with these
people who are 90 years old? They can't
get out of the house.
Their brains aren't really functioning
properly, but they still control all the
money, all the power, and they're
extremely influential. What do you do?
Well,
in most countries, you can't do anything
about it. But Japan is a very special
country where the elderly have a moral
obligation to the nation, to the people.
So, it could be
uh a situation where Japan is in a lot
of trouble, and the elderly voluntarily
choose to exit power and give it to the
young.
All right?
But I think Japan is the only nation
that would do this voluntarily. Every
other nation,
um
basically basically there has to be wars
in order for the young to arise to
power.
All right.
The American Holy Empire.
The nation that is most capable of
surviving
the next few decades of tribulation of
crisis is America. Why? Because America
is so incredibly,
incredibly wealthy, okay? It's protected
by two oceans. It really controls Canada
and Mexico. So, think of America as not
just the continent continent of America,
but really as entire North American and
Latin American, okay? That entire sphere
is basically America.
So, it has unlimited resources. It has
unlimited population. And also, America
and the Americans are the most creative,
the most entrepreneurial, and the most
energetic people in the world. So, I
would bet against America, all right?
But, what I think will happen is that
America will need a new identity in
order to survive the age of tribulation.
They'll go from Pax Judaica Oh, sorry.
Pax Americana, which is a secular,
global
idea to one that is much more
nationalistic, that is more focused on
community and nation. That means
embracing Christianity.
Okay? And I think that Christianity is
what will be the force that we build
America after
the many crises America will face over
the next few years.
The last thing that will happen is
techno-Marxism, okay? Where nations that
um have the resources
want to institute an AI surveillance
state
to better marshal the limited resources
um to basically basically to better
control its people. And this is
something we'll talk about later on,
okay?
Um, but basically, you will have this
sharp
uh, division of people into different
classes. Right at the very top, you have
freedom, but people at the very bottom,
um, become slaves or serfs. Right?
Okay. So, that is it for trends I see in
the future. Again, I didn't say this,
but you have to give the illusion that
this war will end soon, and that once
this war ends, then we'll go back to the
things before this the before this war,
okay? No, the world has completely
changed.
We're not going back to the old world.
We're going to a new world. And what
this new world will look like is
something that we can choose to control.
Okay?
All right, any questions?
All right.
>> [clears throat]
>> So, about the new world, so the
relationships between countries will all
be changed, such as China and Japan, and
you know, those five big countries will
the orders be changed?
Okay.
All right. So, the best way to
understand
the geopolitical situation is that it's
it's constantly in flux.
It's constantly dynamic, okay? Meaning,
you cannot easily divide nation-states
into enemies anymore.
The alliances will constantly shift over
time.
And the nation-state system will also
break apart
into, uh, much more resilient
communities. That's it's possible that
nation states become a series of
city-states. Okay?
So, um basically think about the world
the world in maybe 1930s.
Or maybe even China during the Warring
States period, okay?
Basically, I can't tell you
that we'll go to a new world and then
this is what it will look like. No, it
will constantly change over time.
Okay? Alliances will constantly shift
over time.
It's possible that in the beginning,
um
in East Asia, maybe Vietnam, Japan,
South Korea, the United States, Russia
combine to contain China because they
see China as the hegemon. But then
they're like, "Wait a Wait a minute
here. Japan's rising in power. So, let's
combine against Japan."
Okay? It's a dynamic situation.
But but but basically, what you have to
understand is that everything that
you've been taught in school, everything
that you understand about the world,
everything you believe about to be true
about the world
will change. And so, you have to open
your mind and be ready for constant,
um political flux.
And does that make sense?
All right. Any Any more questions, guys?
All right.
So, um now that we've looked at the
world ahead for the next 10, 20, 50
years, who who knows who knows how long.
Um what I'll do in the next class is
examine how this this war between the
United States and Iran will eventually
end.